The joe rogan experience.
So listen,
man,
last time you were here,
there's a fucking story about the Russian mob.
We tease these bitches.
We let these people right now on Twitter,
they have been going crazy all day.
Do not let Bert Kreischer get out of there without the Russian mob story,
man.
Tell us what the fuck happened.
All right,
this is in 1993 probably I think is what I went to Russia.
I was taking Russian classes at Florida state.
I thought they were Spanish classes because I thought has been this classes
because I was a noon class and I signed up and then I was like fucking sweet
Spanish at noon.
I get phone that in and then I get there and they start writing a new language,
a new alphabet.
And I'm like,
all right,
this clearly isn't Spanish.
So then I said it,
I'm going to leave.
And the teacher's like,
listen,
don't leave.
Um,
because if you leave,
we can't have a class and I can't get my master's degree.
So,
but if you stick around,
I'll talk to,
you have to have class.
I get done the end of class.
She was like,
listen,
don't,
uh,
you know,
if you don't leave when I want to show up at class,
I'll give you a c.
I was like,
done,
done.
So I took Russian,
I took Russian one,
two,
and three because these kids need it.
Another guy in the class to take these classes.
So then finally I take rush,
I'd take her out and four and we go to Russia,
we go to Russia.
But this is Rochelle.
Like when the mob ran Russia,
like are you,
are you guys aware of that?
Okay.
In like the 90s,
late nineties mid nineties the mob ran everything that had to do with Russia.
So when going over to Russia,
you had to,
you had to literally pay off the mob in order to go and study abroad.
So we paid off the mob and they gave us in return to banditos too young mobsters
who would go everywhere with us.
They lived in our hotel,
they stayed with us.
They went on tours with us.
They weren't,
they were did everything with us.
Their names are eager and Sasha and when we got are,
our teaser was like,
listen,
this is Igor and Sasha.
They will be ghosting us with my teacher who was there with me.
It was like during the fucking mob,
Igor,
inside you go inside and they were guy named Bruce and they were like,
and they were,
oh,
it gets worse.
So they were like,
listen,
whatever you do to our class,
do not talk to them.
Do not interact with them.
Do not engage them.
They're only here to shadow us.
So in my head I'm like,
fucking get to know these guys,
right?
Like get a bottle of vodka,
a six pack of Baltic,
go knock on their door.
Now mind you,
I speak no Russian at the time,
no rushing because I had never studied in any of the classes.
So first night there and knock on Igor in Sasha's room and they're having a
party in there like fucking all their friends are in their room.
They lived right next to me and Kendra,
my teacher,
and lived across the hall from Igor.
So knock on their door,
eager,
opens the door and he looks like a fucking thug.
He's got,
he's got like a wife beater on a cigarette,
a beer and he just looks at me in Russia and he just goes,
Shh,
store.
And now as the second he says that I start panicking.
All the phrases I had in my head that I was trying to say all disappear and all
I say that you are in Russian is I am the machine,
you know?
And so,
but I just said,
Ya machine though.
And he went stall and that now I don't know what I said,
I'm like,
did it,
what did I just say?
I'll fuck you up.
Like,
and I go,
I go,
I am the machine.
And he goes,
say it again.
I said,
I have let me see him.
And then he starts laughing and he brings me into the room and he's like,
hold on,
say it again.
And so I say it to the room,
I don't know what the fuck I'm saying.
I'm like,
Oh,
I'm the machine.
And they're like,
you're the machine.
I'm like on the machine.
I said that all fucking night with these guys.
That's the communication we had.
As I said on the machine and Igor and Sasha and I became best friends,
right?
We did everything together.
If we went on a field trip,
they would tell me,
machine,
you don't need to go on the field trips.
Come drink with us.
So now,
uh,
cut to one day,
we have to take a train to Moscow.
No different mob.
Ran The train to Moscow and a driven Tro,
tro Marbury and Moscow and Igor or Sascha.
We're not allowed to cross boundaries and it's all me.
They said,
listen,
we're not going to go with you,
but we've taken care of you.
We've talked to the mobsters on the train and in Moscow because we had to pay
them too.
They had,
they weren't allowed to come with you.
There weren't allowed to come with us.
And we're paying a different mob now to protect us on the train,
make a different mob to protect us in Moscow.
Holy Shit.
So they said,
we've taken care of it,
don't worry about it.
So they take me to the train and they introduced me to our tune.
Who?
Gangsters?
Igor.
Where do you three words at a Ford Dude's Igor.
And there's not a lot of names in Russia.
It's Alex.
Igor or Sascha.
What about fuel?
So,
so Igor,
Igor,
my Igor says,
so these are yours.
This is the machine.
If you give them alcohol,
you'll have a great time.
So even when you are like through the roof,
they're like,
awesome.
Don't worry,
we've taken care of you.
We were sitting in first class.
You're not sitting with your class,
you're sitting in first class to Moscow.
And I'm like,
Holy Shit.
This is what I'm talking about.
And I bring another guy,
John Bolshoi,
big John.
I bring him with me to go sit in first class and sure enough,
man,
I'm wearing fucking FirstClass.
Just meet these two.
Igor,
is John the conductor?
I shit you not the conductor before the train takes off.
Comes into the room.
I swear to you,
rips off the band on this thing says this is a present for the machine.
It would be an honor to do a shot with you.
And I'm like,
Whoa,
this is a fucking right.
So I do a shot with its conductor and we pound this vodka within like fucking 30
45 minutes.
We're done.
All the vodka in the room were drinking hard and my classes all in coach and I'm
sitting in first class and even Negro like let's go get more vodka.
And I'm like done.
They,
these guys run the fucking train.
So we get up,
we walk into the bar cart and a biggie or says machine,
Grandpa Paulo grab,
grab some bread club.
And I'm like,
that's bread.
I'm understanding Russia.
He's like,
grab some,
see it as cheese.
I'm like,
I'm learning Russian.
I'm looking at,
John is standing behind me.
He's like,
Eh.
He's like gratified.
Can I go?
I know that one.
And he's like,
grab all the money,
grab all the approvals.
And I go,
what?
I look around and were robbing the bar cart.
What the,
the bartender standing like this.
Everyone's standing against the wall and I'm sitting behind the bar with a
handful of rubles of Bollenbach in a thing of bread going,
holy fuck.
John looks at me.
And he's like,
just take it.
Let's go take all the fucking cash out of the bar cart,
not making eye contact.
And they're their lunches.
It's the mob.
They ran everything in Russia.
Everything.
Wow.
And so we get done and we'd go back to our room and it's a totally different
energy,
like very like very sketchy,
you know.
And I'm free talks.
I'm like,
fuck,
I just robbed the car like no one else saw anyone rubbed.
The bark are except for me.
And my teacher vow,
who's at the time was our chaperone,
didn't speak any Russian.
She comes to our first class cart,
opens the door and says,
I need to talk to you right now.
And I was like,
listen.
And she goes,
I told you that you're in big trouble.
You I,
my classmate,
your classmates had told me what happened.
Big Ego.
It takes a sip of vodka,
spits in her eyes and goes,
no one talks to the machine like that.
I'm like,
whoa.
He spit vodka in her eyes,
fucking it is,
and then shuts the door and then looks at me and he says,
don't worry,
I got you.
When it gets dark,
we're going to have a lot of fun.
And he pulls out a thing of keys.
He's got keys to the whole fucking train and he's like,
we're going to rob everyone when the,
when it gets dark now I'm like,
fuck,
what did I get myself?
Like this is bad news,
bad fucking news.
So we get stark and sure enough,
then we start robbing the train,
go through my class first and we'd fucking open the door,
the little eagle rock crawl and pull the bags out.
John and I would go through them and try not to steal like anything important
and Biggie or would stand guard.
And if anyone woke up,
he'd take us civil vodka and spit it in their face.
And it was,
I mean,
it's sketchy now.
It's sketchy.
It's not even fun.
They low are these guys aren't fucking no,
no,
no.
They're loaded though.
They're hammered.
Piss drunk.
We robbed my whole class.
And then,
uh,
and then we ended up,
they ended up taking off and going into the car and me and John are sitting in,
in the first class,
conscious thinking,
we're fucked,
man.
We're fucked.
We robbed the train.
We've probed the bar cart and they come back and they're just fucking angry.
Drunk,
like Piss,
angry drunk.
We pull in a Moscow and my teacher,
Val,
uh,
comes to the door,
opens it and said,
I'm just sending,
you know,
we've called the police.
So it was like,
fuck.
So Igor,
Igor,
like,
fuck it.
Don't worry.
Fuck the police.
This is Russia.
Who the fuck she thinks she is?
This isn't America.
This is Russia.
We run everything.
I'm like,
Ugh,
I'm going to fucking go to the gulag.
Sure enough.
Sure enough,
man.
The cops are sitting on the,
on the middle,
like the middle,
you know,
were people get off the train,
that little receiving area.
My class is sitting there,
my whole class,
or in the pajamas,
they're crying.
Their bags had been gone through their fucking giving statements to the cops and
the cops are writing them down.
And I'm sitting with Igor and eager and John in the fucking car,
and they're just still drinking and smoking and they're like,
fuck this,
fuck,
this will take you there to this right now.
They walk outside out to the cops and start yelling at the cops.
And I'm like,
motherfucker,
this is not how I would've taken care of this.
Just,
I don't know.
I don't even know what they're saying.
But they were just shouting and the cops were shouting back.
And then finally biggie or just starts pointing at me and I'm like,
oh,
he's been in this whole fucking thing on me.
Like I'm going down for the whole thing.
And then the cop starts pointing to me and telling me exists,
is it?
Yeah,
it's by the ocean or whatever he's saying,
come here right now.
So I fucking walk out.
And it's that moment where you find the hash on your body.
You know,
they find it and you're going to jail forever.
Is that that moment that walk we were asshole gets cold and you're like,
this is it.
Express fucking.
That's the moment.
And I walk all the way across this little fucking trailer,
get to him.
I get right up to the cop and the cop looks at me and he goes,
I understand you're the machine.
I was like,
yeah.
And he goes,
tonight,
you party with us.
So then we went out and partied with these cops.
So the cops did nothing.
Fucking nothing.
They were so excited to meet the machine.
What it,
we're like this fucking,
it was the,
it was,
it was a nickname there.
No one funny in Russia.
Is that what it is?
No,
there was no,
there was no humor.
There was no so thing with you.
Is that what it is?
Is No one funny.
And then you come along and you're hilarious.
So they like,
we're partying with you.
Yeah.
And I was,
and I was just loud.
Like there's not a lot of Lao people like you.
Would you be willing to move to Russia to be their bitch and to like,
Nah Dude,
those guys scared me one night the guy did you party with these guys?
I partied with Igor and you were on the train only and then I partied with the
cops in Moscow with John and then for one night then we hid from them cause they
want it.
They like the cops.
The cops were,
were scary.
More scary than the gangsters because they could not get in trouble like that.
You,
they were like crying my cop car and you're like,
what the fuck drive my comp cost.
Fucking do they drive on the left side of the right side?
Same side as us.
I don't remember.
I was there for three months.
You'd think I'd know.
I have no idea.
I was drawing on the same side as us,
but I mean like the whole experience in Russia was just amuse.
Just,
I remember one time we [inaudible] going to,
Sasha had said they were going to get a boat for us for Russian may day or Labor
Day.
And they're like,
yeah,
we got to,
um,
they're going to have a big boat for our whole class.
We're all going out in the boat.
So I get up early for the day,
we're going out of the boat and I go over to eagers room and Igor is eating
dried fish,
drinking beers.
And I was like,
what's better?
And he's like,
I'm fucked.
I go,
what?
And he goes,
we got no boat.
Like,
what do you mean?
He goes,
I've,
I've tried everything to try to get a boat.
I can't get a fucking boat.
And we've promised the class of boat for the tour is supposed to have a boat.
And so we're like,
oh fuck.
And he goes,
and then all a sudden the phone rings and he goes,
we got a boat.
I go,
we do.
And he goes,
yeah.
So we start walking to the dock,
we're carrying a fucking big case of beer,
my whole class cameras and fucking do their little passports around their neck.
And one of his buddies just walks up and he's like,
hey.
And he's like,
And then we just get to the dock and there's a boat there and we just get on it
and take off and halfway through we realize like I just stole the fucking boat.
He just stole the boat.
And he was like rushing must be just fucking crazy.
Insane.
We went to,
went to a big mob boss party one night and he was like,
tells them my boss.
He goes,
this is the machine,
this is the guy.
Does this all happen?
It just was loud.
And then,
and then I was partying with Eagle and Sasha so much that like that.
And they just tell their friends,
oh,
you gotta meet this guy,
you gotta meet this guy.
He's so funny.
We're going to have to drink with you and then moved it down.
We're going to do shots with Bert Kreischer.
You gotta be careful,
man.
You.
You are selling yourself as this incredible fun party guy and everyone's going
to want to do shots with you.
Oh,
I don't,
I'm,
I'm fucking,
are you friends with Igor on Facebook now?
Have these,
I tried to find them
on Twitter.
[inaudible]
Alrighty.